violence et squeeze on y est enfin le
dernier épisode à l'isolation [ __ ] ce
que je suis excité en plus on était en
train de bronzer les jambes en l'air
c'est parti on va enfin savoir ce qui
s'est passé
si amanda replay reste en vie si elle
retrouve sa mère même peut-être on ne
sait pas ce qui peut se passer bon en
attendant il faut qu'on marche à deux à
l'heure sur cette plate forme ce qui est
beaucoup moins excitant on doit
retourner dans le vaisseau pour trouver
un moyen d'accéder à la tour
d'habitation sur le monde
une fois qu'on aura réussi à faire ça il
faudra qu'on retrouve ricains de l'amour
de notre vie ne l'oublié pas nous
revoilà dans le vaisseau dans le
sébastopol aller désinfecte mois là
alors retient cette combinaison qui est
super oppressante vos cours montent
ouais watts merde s'est passé un truc
oui et cardo petitpas kanak non non on a
su supporter un chagrin d'amour
le deuxième sera vraiment trop dur omg
sa part en méga gros steak mon gars on a
regardé au plat bientôt quand
d'allemands l'aliène direction ou oui
ces derniers épisodes tu crois que tu me
fais peur tu me prends dessus je te mets
du lancera le dtc fdp on n'a pas le
temps pour s'aider mutuellement la
vienne va charger de cet homme qui nous
tirent dessus au revoir la sauvegarde à
sion est fait on se tait rb6 en hachant
soeur à bientôt et bon j'espère qu'il
tiendra bien l aller on rejoint rijkaard
on le prend sous le bras et ont des noms
c'est un but de merde je suis dans une
colère noire ou rouge ou une couleur un
peu sombre et qui fait peur non mais il
n'avait pas d'enflammer il avait rien
mais non mais il était là tranquillement
avec son joystick tant pis on termine
sur ricardo après tout un de perdu dix
de retrouvés
c'est affreux je suis pas un connard de
vos sentiments dans cette série elle est
où alors voir et ils voient pas ils me
voient pas je vous jure qu'il voit pas à
vous fait confiance ont pas reçus collés
maintenant il m'a pas vu leur garde et à
montauban bayonne ok tu tout le monde
sauf fois on est les prochains vous en
faites pas
il indiqué tout notre sport le petit qu
on y est une reste 119 de lance-flammes
ça sent la merde allez allez allez allez
on se tire on se tire oui la petite
goutte de sueur là vous la voyez ou pas
ce qu on n'a pas ce qu'on a du courage
aujourd'hui alors attention est ce qu'on
va réussir selon ses débiteurs de son
nom ça at-il aliens on a plus de la
flamme voilà je tenais à le dire on
s'est fait un kit mais du coup un pull
en slam là il nous voit on décède 1 et
vu qu'il va pas tarder à nous voir étant
donné que c'est un petit [ __ ] et ben
on va décéder
vous savez quoi ces dernières est plutôt
prospère des kills par exemple on tente
un sprint à les aliens versus human qui
court le plus vite et et on peut se
permettre ce genre de choses ces
derniers épisodes putois dire elle était
descendue de son [ __ ] de conduits à
l'oreille et nous défoncer faut qu'on
continue tous deux sur ce petit bout de
métal les deux utilisent ces saletés u
12 u
ok je vais récupérer un code dans cet
ordinateur si je 18 51 vous retenez
alors c'est là pour mettre au courant
redémarrer les systèmes adéquats mais
moi je peux être courant c'est bon ça
marche ça fait de la fumée ça veut dire
que ça va généralement comme les
voitures ça fait de la fumée ça marche
on dit oh voilà
mais arrêtez savais tu es mon amour vous
voulez me tuer moi mais ça n'a pas payé
suis je vois pourquoi je fais un accent
c'est parce qu'en fait ce que j'ai peur
voilà c'est un automatisme un peu débile
qui ne marchera probablement jamais jo
je fais agresser dans la rue et que je
réponds extinction le mec me cas sera
encore mieux la gueule alors il faut
aller là-bas pour appeler un transit
[ __ ] tu veux dire qu'on va devoir
attendre pendant une minute sans décédé
à lui ouvre toi
non [ __ ] il m'avait appelé vous avez
entendu ce petit bruit là de ses naseaux
j'ai jamais été aussi content des dents
des transports en commun sont déconner
j'ai qu'une envie c'est d'arriver au
bout
me dis pas qu'on recommence depuis début
on doit appuyer transit manga c'est une
blague
oui bonjour oui d'accord je sais pas non
plus désolé ya un problème il ya un
problème d'ascenseur vient pas de la
sauce heures ya un problème d'asthme en
[ __ ] de fuck
oh la la et j'aimerais bien souvient d
une sauvegarde s'il vous plais n'importe
où à gauche à droite devant derrière
abandonné la station [ __ ] arrêtez s'il
vous plaît la blouse et un make up coup
hop [ __ ] non mais là il ya la totale
android aliens le truc et david adore le
code et 19 84 c'est tout ce que j'ai vu
un chiffre gelé retenu terminer quel
parti censé ouvrir 19,84 c'est ça 84 à
les carburants carte magnétique
carburant utilisé la carte magnétique
mon style
et hop on revient la chance d'avoir une
explosion un truc à faire boum on va
voir la vienne à droite ou ya vraiment
un truc et ne faisait pas parce que j'ai
peur et que je suis très sexe est bon on
est là où il faut pas un bruit est pas
vain vais pas même un veste de citron un
homme décédé non pas cette fois
ok ça s'est activée what what what
bouaké parce qu'elle omet rld
pourquoi au oui effectivement trouver un
autre chemin trouver un autre chemin on
était là le point était là et maintenant
il est oui au milieu de nulle pa oh mais
non les sans prévenir quoi j'ai pas elle
pourrait laisser tomber un pépito un
truc pour qu'on sache qu'il ya un dock
au dessus alors ouais l'autre chemin
faut trouver ce taux de [ __ ] de chemin
je suis débile il y avait un truc juste
là pour l'ouvrir aux redémarrer général
mais non mais mais ces dames est cette
meuf n'aura jamais la chance de sa vie
voilà je le dis elle fait un enfant est
mort à elle a un mari miura elle fait un
gâteau il pourrira il est au générateur
mais non mais les gars c'est une blague
c'est un sketch amanda sur scène à
partir du 2 novembre que générateur est
là bas on vient de sauvegarde et il nous
reste trop tard lance flammes
on va gâcher probablement dans moins
d'une seconde voilà donc je désignerai 0
lance flammes
quelle saloperie surgénérateur je vous
jure voilà du coup on doit retourner à
l'autre bout elle nous pousse cette
musique un parcours elle pousse pas du
tout nos compétences a échappé aux
alliés et 11 part je suis tendu là on
est tous tendus alors relâcher un peu la
pression dans un conduit
tu veux dire immunité hop et de ses
passions oui
on arrive on est là dans une minute mais
il ya pas mal d'alien sur le chemin donc
ce sera plutôt sur 20minutes trouve un
moyen d'amarrer le torrent mais on va le
trouver le moyen t'en fais pas ouais la
sortie aux usa mais ça c'est de vieilles
salles aussi épisode un ou deux ça je
m'en souviens 1 et là on ouvre la porte
et on trouve tous nos amis qui revient
d'entre les marrons sais pas trop
pourquoi c'est parti on est dans
l'ascenseur j'ai plaidé pas de nature
agressive mais ne se laissera pas fin à
presque oui j'arrive tu mets pas la
pression se te plaît oui je tends tort
oui oui oui ça c'est où vous précisément
là et là ok j'ai compris il est vivant
il est vivant ou mort a pas deux fois
elle est le petit deuxième et on est
tranquille
le petit deuxième ou et on est
tranquille ou tard pour le deuxième pour
établir le courant est une trappe à mon
avis ça mène aux établissements de
courant oui et maintenant et maintenant
dix mois qu'il est de trucks ont déployé
qu'on peut se battre
oui et là boum et un alien qui tombe au
plus tard je l'avais oublié ta profitait
de la faiblesse pop up mais c'était
verrouillé il ya deux gros on s'en fout
initialiser allez allez
oui amar toi mais ça va aller aussi à on
joue pas je te donne un ordre et tulle
exécute ça va mal finir cette histoire
ça va très mal finir je vous le dis je
lui ai mis un cocktail dessus y'a plus
coordonnées personnelles depuis un bail
je faisais abattoirs de maintenance à la
place c'est sur une combinaison élevage
pas encore vous attendent ce serait bien
oui d'accord dépouille la plateforme de
maintenance mais c'est une blague il
faut faire un nombre de trucs hop c'est
parti
allez c'est moi que ça marche ça y est
allé au saas oh oui oh oui
attention mesdames et messieurs sur les
staffs 1 va-t-on enfin réussi à
rejoindre le tauren star beau mais vos
médias l'un d'eux est allé ouvre toi il
est où le sas il est où le [ __ ] de la
vie au jeu ne risque guère plus le sas
le sas il est là et toi tu viens pas
dans le sas monga crois-moi change de
tenue change de tenue
oh la la la la la la chute tout chut
chut je suis à fond là choix font aller
tu l'a tellement vu ce casque va mais le
avant que la lienne
mais non mais non
oh non on
tous et ben vous voyez ça c'est une des
longues interviews
ça c'est une gagnant d'intervilles mais
non on doit retourner ou saas mais
[ __ ] et c'est incroyable mais amanda
replay est élue femme de l'année de loin
[ __ ] mais amanda mais si je te jure si
tu finis par te sortir mais ces eaux
sont morts regardez les mois là ces
petits des gueux est ce qu'au bout de
tous ces décombres il ya une porte bien
belle bien propre avec dessus marque est
sorti conçu pour un mandat replay non
non non non mais c'est à mon ascenseur
c'est incroyable il ya un énorme feu
alors est ce que tu es un an qu'un
extincteur dans ta poche arrière gauche
à wanda elle est morte
non elle n'est pas morte ça survient
automatiquement envoyé cette icône l'a1
et ben ça veut dire où est décédé au
[ __ ] on est clairement sur les rails
baird
oh arrêtez arrêtez un mandat à courage
oh là là là là bas c'est il va te
falloir là haut et ça va lâcher bien sûr
non mais c'est une blague cette échelle
ah bah oui c'est une blague
non je peux quand même prendre l'échelle
pour descendre un mandat on la soutient
ces poupées dans le public à outreau
[ __ ] mais oui mais si tu te fait la
gueule non
allez hop on s'enfuit et franchement
j'aimerais avoir le bon qu'elle a pour
se sortir de situations horribles et on
est revenu on est revenu au saas annonce
au nom au nom c'est moi
d'accord j'arrive
j'arrive oui bah enfin là on est tous en
temps à tomber alors tu n'en fais pas le
coup du jour hier le casse pendant 20
minutes se plaît 1 et à vous comment ce
[ __ ] mais faux luxe allez on se casse
pas papa ah oui effectivement c'est la
merde voilà on peut pas laisser tomber
verlaine qui nous a attendu pendant tout
ce temps mais les aliens en plus ils
vont tomber sur la terre après c'est
tout ce crash est là vous risquez de
croiser un alien en allant chez vous aux
toilettes par exemple l'atelier falloir
qu'on appelle ce truc
oh la la non mais sans déconner y'a rien
de moins sûr au monde à l'heure actuelle
voilà même sauté à cocher sur une mine
c'est plus sûr que ça enfin
contrairement aux impressions dans ce
genre de scène un merlon la pression est
une petite merde dans une plus grosse
merde c'est l'escalier vers la victoire
on arrive au sommet enfin ton pouvoir
détacher le torrent d'armes entre y
avoir de mécanismes d'un monstre des
bruits le décrocher manuel je vois c'est
bah moi je vois pas donc si vous me dire
ce serait formidable
et de une attache libérer bien y'en
aliens ya un alien monga ya un [ __ ]
daniel à l'aller on se détache on se
détache l'aliène il fait quoi il est là
bas il vient vous dis pas au nom en non
non non mais dis pas qu'ils allaient
poursuivre au camp tout autant il ya
aucun problème n'a même et camon trop de
temps à tuer le sas non mais les aliens
ils vont être 10 vous rentrez ils font
péter le champagne là parce qu'ils
auront investir d'autres vaisseaux me
plaisait mais c'est jamais vu un truc
aussi loin faire sans déconner même
redémarrer un ordi sous windows c'est
plus rapide
le dernier c'est bon le dernier fait
maintenant maintenant on s'accroche est
en surpoids non ça sent pas bon a les
pattes dans là dedans les aliens ils
sont plus là on se demande vraiment où
ils sont 1
non non non non non
s'accrochant samedi
atout qui pète il ya tout fait
vaches
donc est donc complète avec ou pas c'est
ça la question
voilà la mer berbère
qui s'en sort ok énorme explosion et un
chargement week-end suite là vous avez
vu c'est la même musique il y avait au
tout début de jeu convient de surveiller
rencontrer vers l'être sur le pont
regardez c'est là on a rencontré sa
place pour la première fois aux [ __ ] un
manque finalement ricardo c'était rien
allez retire ta combinaison et va voir
verlaine aller ou verlaine moi c'est pas
vraiment ça oh [ __ ] wallace à cannes
ont changé du tout au tout la can après
de son sommeil tu as pas
sochaux est alors gauche
what
le bouton
bordel
eh ben il m'a tuer oui on est en haut
non un mandat
en un mandat au nom amanda honda tu peux
pas nous faire ça après tant de
l'histoire vécue ensemble
monde est
les chercher il y avait un vaisseau qui
est passé il y avait en a les [ __ ]
ça c'est pas une vraie fin ça c'est pas
une femme ou si c'est une fin qui nous
laisse imaginer la suite quoi mais bon
une l on a vu une petite lumière passer
sur son casque on peut se dire que c'est
un vaisseau qui passe par là et qui va
la récupérer mais on peut aussi dire que
c'est un vaisseau qui en a rien à [ __ ]
de nous dans lequel j'ai des aliens
enfants qu'on peut dire plein de trucs
quoi à votre avis est-ce qu'elles sont
soit un mandat j'ai l'impression d'être
comme elle l'a d'être dans l'espace
comme ça evans oui oui c'est la fin de
ce terrible jeu j'espère se laisse mes
besoins plus si c'est le cas on fait
péter les gemmes sur cette vidéo c'était
juste dingue
il y avait une vraie histoire c'est
vraiment rester fidèle au film alien est
aussi beaucoup de stress de moments
vraiment ou pensé que c'était la fin
voilà on pensait qu'on allait s'en
sortir mais finalement non il y avait
toujours un petit alien ou un autre 8
pour 10 rebonds
waouh je suis tout ému je suis tout ému
c'est la fin de ce premier défi depuis
des années sur la chaîne youtube mais
j'espère que ça vous a plu
en tout cas moi j'ai adoré je suis tout
ému sans voix voilà a laissé la fin il
faut se faire à l'idée
merci d'avoir suivi ce live play et puis
peut-être qu'on en fera d'autun je pense
vu comment ça s'est bien passé ont
surtout retrouvé deux de noël vidéo
c'est dur de vous quitter latin trop
d'émotions l on arrête le blabla on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cet
exploit c'était vraiment génial et je
vous dis tiens tu montes bonne soirée
peace